posen wie wirkst mach schneller ich
schon schritte alter funktioniert bis
heute einige filme polen tobis cannstatt
rund zwei mal was genau tut ist ja auch
am start ich muss jetzt ganz kurz also
jetzt eine aufnahme nicht mehr das ganz
kurze rede ist überaus gebe ich mein
ganzes stück technologie und wie kommt
jetzt jeden augenblick und so wird nur
sein essen ab ebenso wenig zeit also ok
rund 8000 wie wächst in brüssel beginnt
mit dem shop pass auf kaufen wir
erwerben
mach schneller ich war schon schlechter
alter zurücklegen was richtig teuer
werden der hat ja schon als er werden
ok bruder oder okay wir haben ja 1006
mir die wachs ausgegeben
ja noch meine letzten rang ja will ich
auf jeden fall ja perfekt lauda ist echt
geil den wollte ich hatte so ein gefühl
okay okay okay vergibt es noch irgendwas
bruder erst mal gekaut mein angeben ganz
wichtig tmg annehmen das ist ganz
wichtig bruder das sind ja selbst hat ja
schon jeden diese cax kind jeden
footballs kind jetzt
er hat ja
[Musik]
du hast ja warum hast du dich dafür ist
einmal jährlich und runter also ehrlich
auf die gobi werde ich auf die lege was
macht es aus
ich sehe natürlich dann in europa erneut
keinen vielleicht doch mal die maus wie
man die maus hast du hast du da gemacht
du weißt du dass dir das ist wirklich
das von geiger zählt die erste folge
kannst du nicht machen
doch kann ich jetzt überweist nächsten
monaten weniger als ob ich jetzt für 300
euro was gekauft haben sechsmal so
funktioniert das hat einfach nicht
funktioniert jetzt ich hab dir überweist
jetzt genau dass weniger was du mit
diesem scheiße video an geld machst ich
schaue aber kein verbraucher ist mir
egal jetzt das markante gucken also du
hast aufmacher als auch ich habe die
resl uhr essen ich hab dir nicht mal hat
der dow ist hat er vier skins gekauft
habt ihr aber wurde es schon wenn er mal
8000 wie wacker chemie wie passt denn
wie soll ich das video nennen hier und
jetzt dieses video übrigens dass das
video mit seiner qualität aufgenommen
wurde ich muss das spontan mega spontan
will man kann die jetzt aufnehmen
weil aber das wisst ihr was bleibt aber
wie hatte mir gehört er wollte einfach
unbedingt dass das machen wenn du dich
muss den hund erfüllen und regen über
tamara ausgeben weil das ist einmal die
gleiche idee nur noch mal also da ist
mir aufgefallen dass rewe ist ein pc
angelassen hat dass er von unserem sport
gegangen ist er ganz einfach 6600 wie
wachs ja kaum also den skin wollte rede
bestimmt auch schon mal haben den geist
hier einkaufen
ganz schön aber fünf minuten reichen die
ja nicht um halt das ja zu kindern ich
meinen guck mal was du siehst das gleich
worten du hast hat damit ihr nicht
ausgemacht habe schon eigentlich siehst
du das 10.000 aber nur 7000 alles gut
ist ja absolut also und auf jeden fall
wieder gefallen hat dann lass gern da
und wenn der ball kam ich auf diese
weise zu begleiten dann können mich
gerne abonnieren dann sehen wir zum
nächsten
ja